the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I think at the beginning of the semester
we had kind of sketched out the broad
plan the and the broad plan was to move
kind of progressively from what were
what are fundamentally individual
decision-making problems to thinking
about more problems of the market and we
returned to insurance which is obviously
something to do with markets so is by
way of background probably remember a
few years ago the world was economic was
in crisis it may still be in one but now
we're told it's not it's so this is a
quote from the president of the World
Bank
it's trying to make the case that this
the crisis in 2008/9 was going to be a
particular crisis for the world's poor
and that's not implausible you might
imagine that you know if you are that
much closer to you know survival or you
have fewer resources than anything that
goes wrong is likely to hurt you more so
that's not an implausible idea I was a I
spent a couple of days with a New York
Times reporter New York Times bureau
chief in India in the pursuit of this
story so I was I was going for something
else and she came along with me and her
so the whole her she was looking for
people who had who this was in a part of
rural India in a very poor part of rural
India and her whole idea was that she's
going to go there and like zelich she
was wondering how these people in the
villages who go to the city to work as
maybe laborers how they would be
affected by this global crisis so she
wanted to this is the new of time so she
was she was she wanted to link up what's
happening in poor parts of rural India
with what's happening in New York so
that made perfect sense and the problem
was that nobody seemed to know there was
a crisis
factor so she would she would go and ask
people so have you heard about this
there's a crisis in the world is there
affecting your job prospects and one
striking fact was this this was in in a
part of rural India that's pretty
backward the paid areas we wore were
mostly conservative Muslim family
and a lot of the migrants had come home
for a Muslim religious festival so there
were a lot of migrants were there we
could talk to them and to the man
literally to the man they said know what
what crises their jobs for anybody who
wants a job it was like everywhere it
was a Sochi we went to the train station
to look for migrants coming back from
having lost their jobs in the cities in
fact we found tons of migrants who were
leaving for the city on the train so
basically the story never got written
and New York fans never had this story
because there was never anything to be
found and it was kind of striking how
how disjoint these two worldviews were
now that doesn't mean I think it was
clear that if you looked at the data
there were people who were losing jobs
and some construction projects had been
shut down it was there was there were
certainly some jobs being lost the I
think the real reason why this was a
this didn't show up in people's kind of
intellectual map as a very big deal is
not because something some bad things
were not happening but they asked but
it's more that they used to having like
jobs being lost and having to find jobs
and things like that as a normal part of
their life that they in other words the
amount of risk that they normally bear
is so large relative to any you know our
perception of risk I'll come and show
you some numbers in a bit our perception
of risk that this was seen as you know
normal turnover certainly some jobs were
being lost to define another job and the
basic basic difference came from I think
their calibration of what is a
reasonable amount of risk our colleague
Rob Townsend who is an expert on
Thailand studied the Thai economic
crisis of 1998 so this was a big deal in
Thailand I mean there was like the Thai
Baht I think harmed and or more than how
it just will and the whole economy you
know several banks came close to failing
have to build out all kinds of bad
things happen raw however doesn't study
the banks he studies the people who live
in poorer parts of northern Thailand and
he has an he has a panel of people for
now for more than I think 12 years but
it was a he has had a long time he had
been following these people or 15 years
something he's been following these
people very long time families and
looking at the economic outcomes so
every few months they go back to the
same families and measure a bunch of
stuff and the same families had
maintained for a very long time it's a
unique data set that he has now one
advantage of that data set is you can
look at what happens in the crisis year
relative to what happens in other years
you having a data set of the same
families for very long time just
descriptively you they just ask what
changed in the crisis year and I think
his number which I still he presented
this at a conference before he came to
MIT and I had to be the commentator the
number was when sort of in a sense is
almost unbelievable until you think
about it so he found the two percent of
the variation in their income was
attributable to the crisis the two
percent of the variation of income of
this families in a war over so if you
look at a family his income varies every
year every six months so you can just
look at the total variation in income
and then you can attribute a particular
part of that to the crisis what what was
stridor crisis and I think his
calculation was about 2% more for the
crisis so that just the reason I make
that point is not to say that the poor
are very very well-off but the opposite
that they are their normal exposure to
risk is so high that this this
additional pieces that come from global
crisis is extremely small part of it and
that's that's sort of I think the way to
think about it is that there's a ton of
risk that any poor person wears all the
time and then there's some stuff that
happens which we think are important
like what's happening in New York and
they're important for MIT and might be
as soon as the crisis hit the first
thing that happened is that we used to
get free lunch and Mondays and Tuesdays
and that was shut down so you know it
was very it was very important we got
some risk from that but it was but if
you think of these people there they're
not getting any free lunches in any case
and so the amount of uncertainty that
they deal with on a day to day basis is
is Dwarfs any any uncertainty that might
come from come from specific episodes
like the Thai sort of banking crisis of
1998 yeah do you have a question
somebody
so I guess popularly speaking like a lot
of people talk about the like lost
decades
bad that was
this is really broad
so I do parts to actually saying both
are important one is do we have the
evidence from other countries second is
part of the reason why this population
is different is that um Thailand is a
lot less urbanized than Mexico so you
you would get many fewer people into
many more people in Thailand operate in
the traditional underdeveloped economy
mode which is that they are
self-employed they have a farm something
like that they are not actually they're
not so I'm sure people so let me give
you a different example which is maybe
even more revealing I was taking a
little further reform but it's
interesting so this is study by one of
us students what happened in the
Indonesian crisis of 1998 which is the
same happen for the same reason which is
and there the the Indonesian Rupiah
devalued by a factor of 3 which is huge
amount of devaluation so something
really big happened to the Indonesian
economy so turns out that the real
incomes of anybody in Indonesia who was
mainly a rice farmer went up during this
crisis the reason is that suddenly the
currency devalued massively what happens
when a currency devalues and use you are
in rice will rice the traded good its
price goes up relative to non-traded
goods your so your haircut prices don't
go up but rice prices go up to his rice
is traded so these rice farmers actually
were better off in the Indonesian crisis
than they were before he then looks at
what happened how do they react and one
of the things that the thing is looking
at is people attending Quranic reading
classes as one of the outcomes and his
basic reason is in two
in them is they think that this is a
social support mechanism who start
attending Quranic reading classes it's a
people who are not rice farmers it's
like government employees teachers
anybody has a fixed income they are the
ones who lost and then the people who
were farmers they they actually were
better off and they were actually less
likely to attend Quranic classes during
the crisis so in other words again a lot
of people in in a country like Thailand
or Indonesia are basically farming
dependent and those people have very
different risk patterns from the urban
employees Latin America is very
different learning is massively richer
also than Indonesia for example Peru is
3 times richer than Indonesia per capita
income in at least in dollar terms it's
also it's also much more organized with
a labor force that so I'm sure the Lost
Decade happened I'm sure that a lot of
urban workers in each of these countries
gets hurt
the main point I'm trying to make here
is that there's a whole - a whole bunch
of people in this countries which will
bear a huge amount of risk even when
there is nothing happening in the world
economy and those are people who are
farmers who are you know laborers in in
wait like you're in construction you
know who are you know people who work
you know sometimes get a job in in like
you know helping out in farms this kind
of people landless laborers of different
kind these people have a very different
risk pattern from the the urban workers
who I think that the direct who who tend
to be the people are directly hurt by
you know big global shocks so there was
not that there were people not hurt he
just they were for many of many of the
people that Rob Townsend was studying
they were just all kinds of stuff were
happening in their lives they were there
these were all farmers and a lot of them
were all kinds of stuff were happening
life many of them very bad and this was
just a small piece of that big story
that's that that's the point that I
think is is is worth emphasizing is that
there's just so much diversity and
there's so much risk so basically what
are the sources of risk I think the
biggest single is just being a farmer
your farmer you'll face huge amount of
risk where do you find what do you face
risk from what's the main source of risk
bad harvest why do you get how do you
get bad harvest rainfall bums
you know locusts if you're used to
dealing with a huge amount of risk by
our standards off of risk the kind of
risk that you know tenured professors
face of course that's that's you know
maybe that's an extreme example they
have a huge amount of year-to-year
variation in income even if those who
don't have a farm
many of them are kept most of them are
casual laborers they are the poor in
most countries if poor countries are
casual laborers the casual laborers
meaning they don't have a contract they
have a daily job the typical way you get
a job is you know you you know in a city
you stand at a street corner and
somebody who wants to curl you know I
need someone do like move boxes comes
and picks up 50 people it takes them
somewhere so it's extraordinarily casual
meaning in a given day you may not get a
job and many of these people are not
employed more than 15 16 days a month so
this is a very very common fact and
there's lots of uncertainty there some
days you some months you may be get
unlucky and you just got there late or
something and then you miss your chance
so the amount of uncertainty that you
have
you are kind of a casual laborer in a
developing country is huge because it's
the uncertainty of in any given day you
have a probability of let's say you know
three out of four of getting a job and
the other other days you don't and so if
you look at like daily income daily
income is extraordinary variable for
most of these people that's just
mechanically almost you just you know
you will somebody street shows up at
that street corner and you know they ask
you to get on the truck and and go with
him and he needs ten people today rather
fifteen you don't get a job so this is
just a core level of risk in this life
which is very different from thinking
about you the kind of risks we think
about most of the time in more developed
country context there's no perks or
protection the other boy side of that is
there's no social protection direct
almost no social protection you know so
but this is a way and not one way to
think about this is this is the this is
wage volatility this is how much your
wages vary and this is not day to day
where variation this is year-to-year
variation across a set of countries this
is real wages so the country the poorest
country is my Alomar and it has
basically you can plot a line that's
almost and that line has essentially you
if you go increase GDP log GDP by one
you get about you half the risk
something like that so this is even this
is conditional on getting a job I said
the big part of the uncertainty is you
just don't get a job but then the real
wages are extremely unstable as well
part of the reason they're unstable
comes from this other fact which is
this this is food prices and if you
spend 60% of your income on food food
prices matter a huge amount maybe one
thing that one big piece of risk that
people have been facing is just that
what's happening to food prices so food
prices have gone as you can see 2006 7
2007 they peaked the the food index
dollar for the index went up to 200 is
it was came down to 140 then went up
bounced around and has been climbing
since so so that's a if so I think about
if you have a that's a 60 percent change
in the in the food price in a year or
sixty four sorry this change from 140 to
200 so that's a change of 30 percent and
that change is if you are spending you
paints spend sixty percent of your
income on food then that's of the order
of like losing 20 percent of your income
in a given year
so just food price variation will itself
have consequence now we just probably
adjust so that's not probably an
overestimate of that but still you can
see one major source of uncertainty
comes from just the fact that food
prices go up massively sometimes and
come down put up and down it's it's a
risk that you see there's also a trend
which is worrying in general is the food
prices seem to be going up
systematically over the last some years
what is a bit misleading about that
trend is that food prices had fallen for
the last the previous 35 years or
something food prices had fallen and so
since 1972 ninety two thousand five food
prices are basically systematically
fallen slightly and then it's been going
up so this is a bit misleading this
picture but still it's lots of
uncertainty
I want to emphasize here it's not levels
with uncertainty food prices are bounced
bounced around a lot if you're poor
that's a very big piece of your income
so just to think about this analytically
there's a so this also matters very much
depending on where you are for example
in your production cycle so a reason why
risk is amplified is when the fact that
you get hit by a shock then affects your
ability to be productive which then
affects your income with then affects
your ability reproductive etc so there
is potentially a vicious cycle that can
be set off by a shock when would that
happen well we have introduced this idea
of offer offer of an s-shape production
function and there's how we read read
EBU Tina's story what's the story
kind of garbage action
which the editor of that contract which
the divorce we try to restart very start
bunch of shorts that the
the children
yeah so thing to emphasize their net
story is that this particular kind of
Shakti fest was a contract enforcement
shop she had two sharks both of which
were basically so first one was someone
he she had basically sold on credit
defaulted and therefore didn't pay back
the money and she had taken a loan to
finance that so that kind of put her
into trouble then she got in order to
supply shorts to being a retail store
and then they defaulted on that they
refused to take the shot so she had she
has very luck then when we met her she
had a huge pile of shorts were sitting
inside her house surrounded by a pile of
shorts like like a lot a lot of lot of
shorts you know 12,000 shorts or
something so she lost a whole bunch of
money on that as well so but then
basically once you the point is that
what is also striking about her story is
this you know this dynamic so but this
this picture does is so that whoa so
it's like that s-shaped curve kind of SS
is a maybe an exaggeration that's that's
the mapping from your wealth today to
your wealth tomorrow so that's that
tells you given today's wealth what your
tomorrow's wealth would be so let's take
that as given now
what would be the main point of drawing
it that way is that if you think of
what's happening around the point P look
around the point P think of a path that
starts just above P where's that part
going explain right any part that start
to the right of P you can see that like
the one example that's drawn the way to
analyze this is to think you know you
start with a particular wealth that
generates that wealth
tomorrow the that wealth is the same
this is tomorrow's wealth then becomes
today as wealth the way you do that is
you map that through the 45-degree line
and you look at where that will be and
you can you that sequence is just going
up to the point where the second
intersection is who doesn't understand
this picture
I'll explain again this will come back
to this picture
okay I'll assume that you're comfortable
with this picture okay I'm not surprised
but just in case and then what key is
that if you're on the other side of P
you're going the other way
so if you're close to P and you get hit
by a shock your well goes down by a
small amount that's not where it stops
you well goes up by a little a small
amount you go up a long way your well
goes down by a small amount you go down
a long way so there's a natural
amplification in this if the the
production technology looks like that
then there's a natural amplification of
a shock a small shock turns into a big
shock here that's that's the point of
that picture
so now it's very difficult for her to
get out because basically she's never
generating enough surplus to make you
know make the investment she needs to
get the next periods output to be high
enough so she's always like cutting back
and cutting back and cutting back and
that's that sort of like so in other
words not only is there a lot of risk
there's a lot of technologies in the
world which amplify that risk so we
already talked about another aspect of
it last time what was that
another aspect of risk kind of an
amplification of risk whatever it's not
quite after we talked about what happens
during droughts who's here
aloud to that you can say allowed to die
are you looking for the it's an awkward
word yeah exactly
so so another aspect of this this risk
is that you sometimes respond to it in
drastic ways so one of the drastic ways
you might respond is by why you try to
do that because you know that
essentially if you you want to if you
had you have two children you can't feed
either of them both of them are going to
be you are going to starve and be hurt
you know the long run where health will
be hurt so you kind of switch your money
to one of them that's another way in
which you sort of maybe create a long
term problem may be one of those
children doesn't die but she starves and
grows up as a as someone who has a
handicap all her life so you amplify
lots of shocks by taking these extreme
decisions under this condition so first
so this this this is just saying that
you know when you when you think that
you can't really so balancing risk is is
difficult it's if you don't have a lot
of money it's not surprising moreover
here's an interesting fact
so this means stress right not just it
doesn't just mean that I as I am
something happens to me I also worry
about it amazing if you didn't worry
about the fact that you know tomorrow
you might have to start one of your
children so this means worry
now turns out that when you worry your
body actually reacts in a particular way
it generates caught results and court
results are a body's kind of defense
mechanism to keep it going under
situations of stress which they are
actually a natural response of the body
to a situation of risk it's probably in
a sense a good reaction from the point
of view of certain types of survival but
there's a lot of lab experiments where
basically what they do is they stress
people out so I think the one that this
is there's a bunch of them with
Princeton students so well not exactly
the world's poorest but the way these
experiments go is they give you an and
endowment and then they take away some
of that endowment and somehow people get
stressed out when you do that you you
you make it even if you know obviously
you're a Princeton student it's not that
you're gonna run out of food there's
plenty of food in the dining halls and
there is you know you're probably going
to have a your lifetime income is
unlikely to be affected by the fact that
you lost five dollars in this experiment
but people get stressed out when you put
them into these situations and then the
experiment is to make them play games
sort of like problem-solving games and
you get a massive reduction in their
product problem-solving ability maybe
they're not MIT students or maybe
this is not as good at it but still you
see you see that they do really badly
when you put them under stress so like
little bit of stress you know some fake
stress basically you you they were going
to get $10 and instead they end up with
two or something and that kind of stress
already makes them take really bad
decisions you might imagine if you had
real stress you know your child could
starve your you know your mother could
die you you could lose your job you know
you're not going to be taking a lot of
good decisions no these are separate so
the games were again good before the
games there were some you created some
general unpleasantness for them they
thought they would get a what they get B
or something you know nothing you can't
do you know one of the rules of
experiments you can't make people worse
off so you need these people were not
made they were first given some money
then some of that money was somehow
taken away from them so this was like
but somehow even that got them so
stressed out that they started playing
games badly
how do I know because I think they
believe the experimenters I don't think
they were they thought that so they were
not they were told from the beginning
that when you join this experiment you
will lose you know someone there'll be
some uncertainty that's gonna be created
for you so I then when the experiment
was done relatively carefully to avoid
the possibility that they think this is
a little mad world I think the most
experiment as worried about that which
is you come and tell me that I'm going
to first I will rue this to you and then
I will rule that to you you start
worrying but but then this there's a
nice field experiment actually in Kenya
which is which has which is measuring
cortisol levels of across people when
they receive
I think they receive some microcredit or
some other program I I'm seeing the
results from it yet but I I've heard
that the results are again very similar
that you're going to get people under
stress take bad decisions so they and
one that you're doing in the field is
that it's it's they're getting real real
help with their stress and then they get
the real help with the risk they
actually take better decisions it's less
artificial but say I think this fact is
is quite crucial in in so understanding
a lot of decision-making among poor
people because they are under a huge
amount of stress and then we are
expecting them to maximize utility over
you know their the rest of their lives
and figure out which financial
investment to make and and you know how
to educate the children and and all
these decisions and get them all of them
right you might imagine that one of the
things that happens when you're under a
lot of stress is you get these decisions
wrong and if you get the decisions from
that helplessly has long-term
consequences for your life so one one
other sense in which risk affects you is
by making you take bad decisions yeah
and for example in our harvest fields
credits
actually a distracting
I think that says yes I mean I think we
at the beginning of the semester we
looked at you know for example just
consumption decisions of the poor you
saw the we what we saw there was that
they were spending large amounts of
money on things that they didn't need to
buy so that's a very simple example
taking the child to be immunized should
I take him today or take take him in a
month and if I don't do it today if I'm
fully forward-looking rational I might
decide look I might as well do it today
because I'll never do it in the future
but if I'm subject to making bad
decisions I might easily easily make a
decision on that which kind of you know
should I spend the effort to and the
money to purify my water or not yeah I
can miscalculate on that say low is the
risk I could think the risk is smaller
than it is for example so I did that
actually I would almost put it the other
way around I think we who live in like
rich people have most of the decisions
taken out of their hands for example you
know I don't know take any savings
decision mostly my savings decisions are
taken by you know MIT and then I'm
there's some plan which I'm supposed to
join I joined that plan when I joined
MIT and I've not changed anything I
don't have to plan my retirement I you
know I don't really have to get to
decide you know I don't have any risk
mostly unless I do something really
awful I don't lose my job I don't have
to I have to take many decisions on like
you know should I go look for a job
there or there I just come to my office
and I'm done I have I don't have to I
don't have the choice of not immunizing
my children because to the extent that
they I want them to go to school the
school basically enforces that you can't
get your children to school without
immunizing immunizing them this most
decisions are actually of this class are
taken out I don't know whatever water
supply I turn on the water it's clean I
absolutely don't have to take the
decision or whether should i purify this
water if I give
to my son or not is a decision I don't
have to take why because the waters
infrastructurally cleans before it
reaches me it's it's I get clean water
so it's not I don't have to worry about
that I don't have to worry about whether
or not my house can be made out of
things which can catch fire because I'm
there's a before the house can be built
an inspector comes and checks it out and
and I'm not allowed to build a house
that's can catch fire so there's so many
respects in which I'm just I don't have
any choices or given to me whereas if
you're poor you actually have a thousand
choices I mean I actually I think that
there are many too many choices you have
to make if you're for me like think of
water every day you have to decide
should I clean the water or not that's a
that's a that's a difficult choice to
make on any given day yes someone else
yeah
like me
because of
I think that's we don't know the answer
to that's a very good question one day
we'll know the answer to that this is
this is all like this whole Court is all
stuff we've only figured this out in the
last two or three years we're just
beginning to get into the these kinds of
questions in a scientific way maybe in
15 years we'll know the answer to that
question right now with this is one
thing that I think it's very very very
recent this understanding that this
connection between cortisol and decision
making and then the fact that khat is
also related to risk this whole thing is
very recent so I don't know the answer
to it's a perfectly good question
I just don't know
so
now obviously people don't take risk
sitting down I mean you know they do
something then do stuff about it so one
thing you can do is you can you can you
can borrow you can go to and say that
look I don't have any money today I I
didn't you know the truck didn't pick me
up why don't you give me some money and
certainly people do that will see that
it's pretty limited and very expensive
so the alternative is to save so you can
do you can borrow you can save will come
to insurance later but like you can do
one of mostly most people they do one of
few fairly limited number of things you
can you save now savings is is a pretty
good way to deal with so the so imagine
that you face a lot of risk and you
can't borrow your decision rule more or
less is the follower it should be the
following you should consume the optimal
decision rule whether people can figure
this out
it took a Princeton economist and a
computer to figure this one out so maybe
people can't figure it out but let's say
they can then the decision rule should
be to consume everything when your
income is low everything you have and
then absolutely income crosses a certain
threshold you should save the rest and
you should build up a stock for those
days when things go wrong problem is
that if you get two or three bad years
in a row doesn't this doesn't protect
you at all and so this is this is the
next picture kind of shows that a little
bit so this is a simulation this is
nobody real this is a
simulation of what happens when you have
income consumption and assets okay
so income is bouncing around when income
is high you're accumulating assets then
at some point when income you know is
low for a few years your assets keep
getting run down some point it hits zero
then if you're lucky an income goes up
right then then you keep going up then
then you know your assets go up and you
keep saving you're fine but sometimes
you can see that like in the middle
there is this place where income goes
down sharply and it goes down like
there's some period on which several
periods for which is going down that
sharp kind of knife you know the in the
right in the middle and you can see that
what's happened there is your assets
have it's zero and because you axes have
hit zero there's no way you can you know
just pull down your assets and you know
protect your consumption there's nothing
you can do about it and that's when you
see consumption really dropping so most
of the time you see consumption is a lot
flatter than income and that's what
people find in the data consumption in
general is very flat relative to income
but there are periods when it plunges so
if you get two or three bad shocks then
it really hurts one one bad shock you
can deal with but two or three and you
run out of all assets and then you
suddenly your consumption drops
massively so you keep protect your
consumption for a few periods but then
if you g-shock continues then you
suddenly you get into starvation so you
get that picture is actually roughly
what you find in the data that people
like you know two or three years or two
at least two or two years in a row maybe
they just make it the consumption for
the third year of the
again Falls then they they get going to
come into starvation so that that's
that's a pattern that you see a lot and
that's exactly what you'd expect you
people should try to protect their
consumption till they can by you know
running down assets and expect that next
time next time in term will recover but
income doesn't recover after several
times then you get hit very badly and
that's that's sort of what do we find
also in the data this is the pattern we
all to see the data another thing you
can do is try to work more
problem so one thing you can do it and
everybody does that when you when you
can't can't you don't have you know
let's say when your there's a drought
and you can't your farm you go and start
to sell labor problem is we're in the
drought it's a drought for everybody
else everybody's selling Labor what
happens to wages wages keep going down
so in particular it could very well be
that in a drought everybody ends up
trying to work so much and wages go down
so much that that amplifies rather than
then reduces the risk because everybody
tries to work so I'm going to try and go
and try and get work assuming that you
know everybody else is not working but
when I try to go to get to work
everybody else does as well let drive
down wages to the point where it could
even be that it does nothing to protect
me I just end up working more and
earning the same amount of river and
otherwise so this is something that is
this real so there's a paper by see my
jayachandran
who basically looks at this and what she
does is she she adds another wrinkle to
it so she says well how much you're
going to do go out and look for a job
but says sort of this safe depends on
whether you have a bank account or not
so if you have money in your bank
account you're less likely to go out and
find an extra job and more likely to you
know live off your bank account or at
least partly live off your bank account
so you're going to be less desperate to
find work let's go to drive wages down
less so what she does is she looks at
what happens to wages in drought drought
drought years versus non drought years
in eight areas which have good banking
services versus areas which don't have
good back
services so this is data from India and
she's comparing comparing areas which
have good banking services versus areas
that have don't have such good banking
services and looking at the effect of
that on wages in drought years versus
non drought years so in drought years
wages are very low
she's asking our wait is that much even
even lower in areas where areas where
the the banking services are worse or
alternately our wage is relatively less
likely to fall in a in a drought here
where banking services are better do you
see the motivation for that okay so
that's the next table
so so when crop unit goes up which is
basically rainfall in a so this is
always with district fixed effects so we
are comparing the same district over
time the way is in the same district
over time over this period 1956 to 87
this over this 31 years we are comparing
districts districts the same district in
a drought here in a non drought here and
then we are looking for banking is
something that improved over time so in
particular if you look at the last
column banking is also something that's
changing over time and she's she's
controlling for that so and then she's
asking is it the case that where the
banking is better the effect of a of a
good yield in increasing wages is
smaller that's the same question as the
effect of bad yield in decreasing wages
is also going to be smaller so it's
going to mean
wages the effect of yield on wages is it
smaller in districts which have which
have is smaller in districts which have
better banking services and that
negative in crop yield intersector
interactive banking that negative row in
the middle says that yes the effect of
yield on on wages is smaller where
banking is better as you'd expect
people are less desperate there they can
go to the bank instead of you know
working and therefore the falling wages
is smaller in those places now we talked
about saving we talked about borrowing
there's a third thing you could do or
for we talked about saving little
crowbar on it after working there's a
fourth thing we could do oops most
dangerous the 40 you could do is you
could avoid try to do things to avoid
risk so you could so for example what's
an example of doing something to avoid
risk
diversify we investing give me an
example that sounds that sounds right
but general principle give me an example
of what you mean by diversify so one
example would be imagine there's a high
you know you if you could grow there's
two crops sugar cane and wheat sugar
cane it has make is much more profitable
but wheat and sugar cane a subject to
independent risk so you know when sugar
cane dries up that doesn't affect wheat
and when we dries up that doesn't
effectual okay they're just different
different things affect them then by
having a little bit of sugar in a little
bit of wheat you you you have less risk
but of course you're paying in in income
you'll be taking less income because
we're sugar here is more productive so
one thing people do is they they
diversify fact it's like a very
interesting paper from many years ago
showing up they diversify in many very
complex ways one one thing that was very
interesting is you'll find that in many
in most many countries actually you find
that people the the plots people crop
are not adjacent like and that seems to
make no sense I mean you know why would
I farm over here for in the morning you
know walk you're three kilometres over
there and farm in the afternoon and
doesn't seem to make any sense unless
you think that they're like some kind of
micro climates so it might rain here
when it's not raining there and it's
really or maybe there is some when a bug
attacks here it doesn't attack over
there so even when you go in the same
crop you grow it over several plots and
the plots are not contiguous you walk
from crop plot to plot to avoid getting
having exactly being in the same place
because you in the same place then the
same rainfall patterns or the same bugs
are you subject to them if you had
multiple plots in different places you
can avoid that now that's of course
wasteful
because you you are spending a lot of
time walking and you should have been
spending that time farming but at least
you reduce risk so the general principle
is that you you do many many things to
like diversify have many crops many
plots many jobs the there's a study of
how many how many professions a family
can have and I think the maximum number
in that study was 27 they were doing 27
different things like you know they were
like small things like you know going to
the pond and harvesting muscles for the
that was you do that in the morning then
you go and collect firewood for sale
then you go into your yours your son
goes and takes the cow to the field and
your your daughter feeds the chicken so
you had to add up all those little
things but they were doing 27 different
professions I think was the number if I
remember right but that's basically a
sort of extreme version of this avoiding
risk by doing a little bit of many many
many many things the problem that that's
good it allows you to avoid risk but
it's bad because
you know you you end up doing things
which are not particularly productive
you know you don't do the sugarcane it
was sugarcane is much more productive
than wheat so you lose money and he that
keeps you poor so it's estimated that if
there's no weather risk and so you
didn't change your crop mix mix to deal
with the risk you would be 30% more you
will make 30% more money so that's big
that's a big you basically the stuff
that you're doing to protect against the
risk is reducing your income by 30%
another thing that it does is that
because you are doing so many things you
don't like
we had good to add any or any one of
them I mean one way to get good at a
profession is by working very hard at it
learning the job so a lot of these
people for example they don't they don't
want to go to the city and become a
full-time worker in the city why because
they think they'll lose the job and if
they the when they lose their job if
they still have the farm at home they
can come back to the farm and get a
living from that but if you if you if
you that means that your job in the city
is a temporary job if I am hiring
someone temporary I have no incentive to
give that person any skills you know I
know he's going to be gone in a month so
nobody gets taught any skills why
because they're all temporary laborers
but why are the temporary laborers
because they don't want to put all their
all their money into this one one basket
all the eggs into this one basket
because they think that you know if you
know suppose I lose that job what's
going to happen I might as well keep my
foot in farming and so they keep their
foot in farming they keep their foot in
in in the city they keep their foot in
farming sugarcane they get to keep their
footage
charmeuse farming wait the something
they do many many different things that
means they don't get good at anything
and they don't take advantage of what
they're good at
so one one other thing you could do is
is actually offer insurance the
alternative would be to all of these
strategies in there yeah
the logical alternative is insurance
insure what is what is insurance what is
what would we whether insurance
what's an insurance what does is one
more to it yet comminity of insurance
people
specific exposure to certain ice
she paid largely the
what does the contract look like I'm
asking a simple question you're right
so you say you pay if the weather is
really bad you give me a thousand
dollars and I pay fifty dollars in a
normal year or something that's that's
that's it yeah say something
did a better job of sort of dealing with
these issues they say like
Mison unit or something what
they had kind of somewhat strong
functioning central states that
redistributed like he doesn't even have
money or sort of markets in the modern
redistribution yeah so we've talked a
little bit about that in the end which
is you're talking about I think
something very important which is what
what would public policy look like here
and you would want some way to to ensure
people but let's go but I'm asking and
right now I'm asking a narrower question
which is how Woodham if there was a
problem market I was facing risk and
those insurance market I I could buy
insurance right I could if I'm worried
about risk and I'm doing all kinds of
inefficient things to avoid risk I could
get it I could deal with it by just
saying look you know I'm gonna buy
insurance on the weather when weather is
bad I'm gonna get money so here's a
weather insurance product in Ghana this
was offered at different prices to
different people the striking fact here
so when you offer it at a price of zero
people are willing to take it not
entirely surprisingly however if you
offer them at a price of as a price goes
up they'll actually actually fair price
is what is it actually fair price if I
can say the word correctly
right so the amount I pay you in
expectation is equal to the amount you
pay that's actually fair price you can
see that some people buy above the
actual refer a fair price why is that
sorry mr. Bo's so you may be willing to
pay the market economic theory would say
you should be willing to pay more than
the actually very fair price why because
you know actually fabric says on average
you break even but you know you but risk
hurts you a lot so you don't want to
break even on average you wanna you're
willing to pay extra money to get rid of
the bad things that happen when your
money so you risk hurts you more than
just you know it's not just that you
know sometimes you get more sometimes
you get less the fact that sometimes you
get less is worrying you is making you
do do bad things that are inefficient so
you should be willing to pay more than
the actually fair price to get insurance
because that's the whole idea of
insurance we typically when car
insurance is almost hugely not fair if
you look at the you know the car
insurance we have the u.s. why do we
have that because we don't want to we
want to be covered against the
possibility that sometimes people will
sue us for a million dollars in damages
so we are and so we willing to pay a lot
more than what's fair so these people
they're not willing to pay at and the
fair price 30 percent willing to take it
at and you have to really go down to
about a price of one to get that's 1/9
of a fair price to get people to take it
so really people don't seem to want
insurance so if everything I said so far
was true why don't they want insurance I
mean I said they did all the kind these
inefficient things to deal with risk
isn't that immediately telling us that
they should want insurance
yes but
so and in fact when they take insurance
good things happen so why don't the one
so this picture what it shows is this is
P this is the people who this is
spending on total chemical spending is
an odd title well I I didn't put it
there but it was it's total spending on
chemical fertilizer so how much
fertilizer do you buy well when you get
insurance you buy about you know a
little bit more than in control so some
people were offered insurance some
people will offer credit some people
were offered both and you see there's
some gains in in investment people under
invest when they get when they get so
relative to getting just the loan
insurance really help so you when you
you get a you get a loan you don't want
the loan if it doesn't come with
insurance because you then you worry
that you can't repair the loan so you
don't actually gain much so if you offer
the loan you gain nothing but Union
offered loan and insurance then you your
your investment goes up by about almost
over 50 percent so you really invest a
lot more in fertilizer when you get
insurance and credit together relative
to getting just credit so that says that
that affects your income this says that
this affects your welfare when you get
insurance and credit you you are
actually about half as likely to have
somebody in your family miss a meal
that's an extreme form of risk you're
just starving because you don't have
money then that that hobs when you offer
insurance insurance very good for these
people why don't know they wanted the
insurance seems to be increasing output
and reducing risk
yeah
waters and ketchup
the people missing meals and that was
down dramatically dramatically yeah but
why is it that if they have just
insurance or just capital increases oh
really
it doesn't really increase it's like as
you can see it doesn't really you you
need both you need both to for it to
work
so when they insured and there are two
tuned versions of this question one is
why I'm there buying insurance in in the
market and the weather is why I'm there
buying if they don't buy insurance they
can still do something else which is one
way to get insurance is for us all of us
to just pull together the government
doesn't have to do anything the market
doesn't do anything we all live in the
same village we can all get together and
we can all adopt the rule which says
that if any of us loses 50% of the
income we'll all pay them 1% of our
income we could adopt that rule right
and that would be would me everybody
would insure everybody because they're
like 50 of us in this room we lose a
little bit of if I lose 50 percent of
income all of you give me 1% of your
incomes and I'm I'm okay so you you can
you can insure me we don't need a market
to do it we can just do it at the
community level yeah
across like a larger geographical area
where presumably absolutely but we
should at least do that the fact is that
people don't seem to have they have to
seem to have limited assurance even from
their friends but it wouldn't thank you
that essentially of the huge exposure
what in the sense that like let's I mean
I guess you can you can adopt a rule
which basically says let's take an
average income of everybody and then
those who get more than average in that
given here give a little bit to the ones
who get less than average you can always
do that so so in substance it's it's a
puzzle why don't they buy it from the
market why don't the bike from each
other and you know there's been a lot of
hype in this area and people have been
like Forbes magazine had this issue
where they said the insurance for the
poor is that is an unfair trading
natural market and a lot of microfinance
institutions have been talking about the
next microcredit revolution is micro
insurance so they're going to provide
insurance to people but in fact we don't
see very much insurance being supplied
or demanded now insurance is difficult
for a variety of reasons does anybody
know what moral hazard is
the concept that
one problem with the insurance but this
is not this doesn't explain why people
don't want it it just explains why it
could be expensive is that you know if I
offer insurance to you and I say that
you know I'll take I'll take care of you
whenever your income Falls your
incentive to stay home goes up a lot
that's more however what's adverse
selection yeah the other worry is that
you you tend to draw in the people so if
I offer people the option of you know
I'm going to whenever your income Falls
I'll take care of you I might only get
the people whose income is already they
know that income is going to fall come
and join that scheme that's adverse
selection so we have both of those and
then this outright fraud because you
know people might claim their income has
fallen but in fact the income hasn't
fallen you know how do I measure that so
it it's expensive to deliver that's
that's a given but nevertheless the
reason why so you might think that but
you would imagine that at least some
forms of insurance should exist one is
catastrophic health insurance like you
were in a traffic accident you know
nobody gets into a traffic accident on
purpose very little moral hazard
why isn't there insurance for that at
least another one is whether insurance
whether you know you know I don't
control the weather so you know there's
no moral hazard or adverse selection you
know I don't control the weather the
weather is what it is so why don't I
just well if you say that why don't we
get lots of markets for rainfall
insurance when the rain falls you when
the rainfall is below
some cutoff I pay you money otherwise
you pay me money so we would at least
expect to see these kinds of insurance
is difficult to have like more complex
insurance maybe there's some fraud or
something but this kind of insurance why
do we see more of it in the world so
I think so this is this is a sort of
whoa where were we beginning to
understand so there was a huge hype like
five years ago or everybody the world
was talking about how the next unit even
revolution in micro-insurance and then
the revolution kind of never happened
factory was kind of if you like we work
within a microfinance organization to
offer insurance and after about a year
they basically said look we guys we
can't do this we're losing clients every
day because they were forcing their
clients to buy insurance
the way you avoid adverse selection is
they're forcing people to buy it like
you don't want to have people have
choice otherwise only the sick people
will buy health insurance they're
forcing all their clients to buy health
insurance as a result all their clients
were deserting them so they basically
cancel the program so nobody who seems
to want insurance no it's it's really I
don't think people people have fully
understood what's going on there I I
certainly don't I mean like I think part
of it is people don't understand
insurance so the part of the part of the
problem is that people think oh I'm
giving you money and if you don't if I
don't use this service you should you
should give me money me the money back
so you know the idea that I'm giving you
something I see move for most of us the
bizarre thing or insurance is a product
that you you really don't want to use
right insurance is one thing but you
want to buy it but not use it I'm happy
where I don't get sick and therefore I'm
really happy when I paid for it and I
didn't get anything but that's a
psychologically it's an odd product in
that sense it's a product that you're
happiest when you don't use it so that's
one problem clearly it's a bizarre
product it's one unique kind of product
which you know you usually we're happy
when we we get what we paid for here's
when you get you happy when you don't
get what you paid for and that makes it
difficult second thing I think is
they don't trust the insurance company
and there's some evidence that when the
insurance company has come through an
NGO which people know and like they're
more willing to buy it so it's a sub
trust element there well I think there's
something else that I think is is
difficult so think of catastrophic
health insurance I'm going to I'm going
to whenever you get really sick so I
theory is that this this M if I was
offering catastrophic health insurance
the theory was very simple nobody gets a
heart attack on purpose you know
nobody gets cancer on purpose so let's
just ensure those things that was okay
the theories seem to work problem is
people also die from other things like
they they get you know they get some in
the stomach hearts and they'd you know
they they probably got an infection and
died that's not covered by the insurance
because you know in general you know
it's only particular conditions that are
covered now if people don't understand
why you know one thing that is covered
in another thing is it and if you
explain that well there's more moral
hazard in this one than that one then
it's too hard to explain so basically
insurance products name out of the
necessity of protecting the insurance
organization from adverse selection
moral hazard tend to be incomplete they
cover only a few conditions people don't
understand this condition so there was a
big fight with the way this all MF I we
worked with they got into this big fight
with a group of women who were very
upset because someone of their friend's
husband died he died at home he suddenly
got sick and died she when he got sick
she went to the local doctor
and brought like the local doctor
recommended a whole bunch of medication
expensive medication which was useless
with the doctor I think was bad
the insurance never said you know this
was not this is not a covered condition
we can't pay pay for it because it was
not covered in fact all the insurance
company in this particular case said
will only cover ten conditions that
require hospitalization and will only
pay if you have been hospitalized that's
a very good way to check whether people
are making up conditions or not so they
had imposed this hospitalization
condition which was to protect them but
then these people said look you know my
husband died how could it be worse you
have to pay so there was a big fight the
insurance company refused to pay as a
result all of them quit the MFI so you
know just the nature of the product is
difficult I mean that's one final
psychological element which i think is
also difficult which is catastrophic
insurance is a particularly a product
that makes you have you value it when
you think about your own death or
something or something really bad people
don't like thinking about those things
so they had to get people to irrational
about you know buying a product that
involves contemplating really awful
things happening to you so a lot of
people are both I think a little bit
maybe maybe they are little bit as you
know superstitious about it so they'll
really like taking on this risk thinking
about these states or awful things
happening so if you can only insure us
to ensure awful things like when the
crop completely dries up that's not what
people want to think about so that's
another reason why so but in general we
don't fully understand why people aren't
buying these products but if they aren't
buying them okay so if there's no
question I'll stop here
you